I think Bon Scott knew he was going to die, not the date, not the hour, but he knew he was coming
fast. I think he traded something to get even more badass, more famous than he already was before,
and he knew he was going to cost him everything. That's why he wrote Highway to Hell.
Listen to Bon's voice on Highway to Hell, especially the title track. It always intrigued me,
it's different. Am I the only one who notices that? In the early ACDC tracks, Bon is like a
coiled spring, like someone ready to jump into a fight. Pure energy, swimming upstream,
but by Highway to Hell, something shifts. He sounds looser, warmer, floating downstream.
It almost sounds inebriated, but it's not alcohol. This is different. People who know about these
things might pick up on it. It's like a supernatural nonchalance. And what about the lyrics?
No stop signs, speed limit, haste Satan, paying my dues. I'm on the highway to Hell. That's not
just swagger, that's like acceptance. He's describing a momentum that he's decided not to resist.
It's also hard to argue that it's not his best work. It reminds me of a story, a story that was
well known by people like Bon. It was known by absolutely anyone in the rock and roll scene in the
60s and 70s. Picture at this, it's 1931 in Mississippi. It's the dead of night. Nothing but the heat,
insects, and a lonely dirt road intersection. A young musician stands there with a guitar. His name
is Robert Johnson. He's got a burning hunger to be a great player and for fame. Just then,
a dark figure steps out of the blackness. It takes the guitar, tunes it, plays something
impossible. It plays something impossibly good, then hands the guitar back and says, now it's yours.
But understand kid, it ain't free. Everybody knows that Robert Johnson sold his soul to the devil
for immortality. He came back different, transformed. The other musicians were stunned. He now had
supernatural ability on the guitar in otherworldly voice. The devil also promised him fame. But Johnson
died early before seeing it happen. He did become a legend just only after death. Take the 27 club,
Jimmy Hendrix, Janice Chaplin, Jim Morrison, Kurt Cobain, and many others. Same equation,
they traded something for greatness, for art. Some might say they sold their souls for fame.
Well, they certainly got their money's worth.
Bond wasn't 27. He was 33 when he died. But the bargain doesn't care about birthdays. It cares
about cost. And the devil always gets his due. So who is the devil? Well, for many, he's found at
the tip of a hypodermic needle. Yup, heroin. Legend has it that it can make artists feel invulnerable,
lucid, insulated, and brilliant until it takes everything back with interest. That's the bargain
in chemical form. Let's stop pretending this would be impossible. If you like music from the 60s
through the 90s, check your record collection. Most likely a lot of the artists you listened to were
in the grips of that substance during their most creative periods. Some survived, some paid the price.
Late 70s music culture was saturated with heroin. It wasn't fringe. It wasn't rare.
It moved through elite rooms, working bands, after parties, and studio circles.
Some of the biggest artists in modern music have openly talked about it. John Lennon talked
about it. Eric Clapton lived it. Lou Reed built songs out of it. Keith Richards survived it.
It's not a fantasy. It's documented rock history. So the question is not
would an artist like Bond Scott ever have been around heroin. Of course he would.
The real question is whether in that final stretch, he crossed from proximity into experimentation
or even dependency. Given the era, the access, the circles, the schedule, and the pressure,
hmm, you decide. Now the death itself. February 1980, London, night out, drinking. He was left in a car,
overnight, found unresponsive the next day. Official cause, acute alcohol poisoning.
Here's what bothers people. In a case this culturally and commercially important,
the public facing record feels thinner than the legend around it. He drank too much.
That sentence may be true at one level. It may also be incomplete and less plausible than the
alternative. Bond was a veteran drinker after all. And why did his friend leave him in a car
on a winter night? London nights in February are freezing. Why wasn't he checked on until the
afternoon the next day? It doesn't make sense. It leaves a lot of questions unanswered.
So if it was a heroin overdose, why would they have covered it up? Why would anyone prefer the
alcohol story? Because it's 1980. In 1980, in media narratives, heroin was tied to nightlife
subcultures that mainstream rock audiences viewed as alien, like disco, queer, and art scene spaces.
And that stigma made the story commercially explosive. ACDC was trying to further conquer the
American market. You have to understand their demographic at that moment. Working class,
mainstream, suburban, beer, denim, v8s. That crowd was explicitly anti-disco and suspicious of
art scene posturing. And in the public imagination of that era, heroin read as downtown junkies,
disco bathrooms, punk squads, self-destruction, and gay. So a heroin narrative around Bond would
not just be bad press. It would feel like cultural betrayal. ACDC were just about to put out
back in black. The thought might have been, who's gonna buy a back in black if Bond Scott just
died like a velvet underground groupie? Look, in 1980, radio gatekeepers were conservative.
Advertisers were risk averse. Program directors would have backed away fast. A heroin story could
freeze momentum instantly. Just five months after his death, you saw back in black in every record
store in America. Fifty million copies sold. That's a lot of money. You don't need a secret
committee to cover it up. You need self-preservation. You need everyone to choose the least explosive
explanation. So given all this, did Bond Scott know that he was going to die?
I think he heard the bill coming due. I think he kept playing. He kept walking. The devil
hot on his heels, ready to collect. And we consumed it all as entertainment. Either way,
play highway to hell tonight. Loud. Then tell me he didn't know.